so my [ __ ] the next speaker is a
shepherd and he will tell us about home
techniques for differential trust I
guess it's like anchor I also change the
title of the talk you know everyone
talks about new stuff I want to talk
about old stuff ok ok ok so whenever I
mean this talk is about differential
privacy and whenever I talk to
non-experts about the friendship privacy
I give them like I start with this feel
that it is the notion that into my
analysis i'm going to introduce this to
her into my analysis i'm going to
introduce cleverly design and carefully
calibrated based on your data in your
analysis random noise to into your
analysis that will mask out the effect
of any single person and and and you
know i am fully aware that when they see
this I even tell them you know they
should be infuriated they should see it
and say you know you wanna take my data
and you tarnish it with random noise and
that's inconceivable how can you do that
and and I tell them you know take that
infuriating and table it that's not what
I'm going to tell you what I'm going to
tell you is that in fact there are many
analysis analyses out there that are
using randomness as is and the as it
turns out from the song these analyses
when their caliber currently also
preserve differential privacy and you
know it's a non worst case so when the
inputs are nice you can literally take
them and run them as is ok so now that
I've given you the natural version of
the talk the longer version of the talk
will be like this but yeah I will start
with a feeling differential privacy
because I know that not everyone here I
mean I'm pretty sure that everyone have
heard of differential privacy but i'm
not sure that everyone really get the
idea i'm not sure that i wouldn't help
maybe like infuse more but
try I'll talk a little bit about perfect
linear regression then I talk about more
linear regression related in lovely
distributions that are connected to
gaussians and finally conclude with the
privacy terms okay so what is
differential privacy you know to give
the definition of differential privacy
force complicated life and give another
definition neighboring data sets are
data sets the differ dust in a single
person all other n minus people n minus
1 people are the same you know someone
up and up tau or changes into whatever
awkwardly creature and then an algorithm
a randomized out work and they said to
be differentially private if the
following game happens you choose any
neighboring data sets therefore just on
one person you know and you know the
data sets and you know the person they
differ I'll pick one of them i'll run
like computation over one of them in
secret and show you the output and even
though you know that it was one of these
two data sets and you know the result of
my output you still are not really able
to figure out whether i use the one or
the other and to actually formalize it
we use a quantification we say that the
algorithm is epsilon delta
differentiated private where epsilon
controls the multiplicative version of
how much the outcome can be is more
likely to be or not and delta controls
the edited version the additive term of
the change into the probability and the
classic algorithm that preserves
differential privacy is the additive
random noise mechanism that's basically
says well if i have a query and you you
know it's tender choir and data sets and
how many people satisfy so-and-so
property this query exhibits low
sensitivity when i change only one
person only the value of the query
changes by no more than one so what I'll
do is I'll actually take the value of
the query and add to it some random
noise hence the name additive random
north and and you can see for yourself
right if the value of the query is 17 on
one data set and 18 on another data set
and I picked one of them and I sampled
you know 20.0 three you look at the
result of my computation so which one is
more likely to come from the blue
distribution or distribution yes the
right distribution but not by a lot
that's why I'm preserving five
with this additive random noise approach
now as I said I'm going to tarnish the
reputation of introducing air inter
computation that are of course is
independent of n so the classical
approach the classical triangle that we
have in differential privacy analysis is
privacy versus accuracy versus the size
of the day if I want a good guarantee of
privacy not too much private privacy
Lawson if I want a good guarantee of
accuracy being fairly close to the to
answer but the size of data has to be
large differential private analysis
about the trade of between these three
quantifiers okay linear regression we
all know in love linear regression it's
one of the things that people do on many
data set you know someone comes and
asked me Oh predict this particular why
as a linear function of all the other
X's and I open my undergrad notes and I
run the linear regression computer via
and I find the linear regresar and since
it's one of the most basic things that
people want to do on data sets the
question is can we do it with for
differential privacy and the answer is
yes I mean comerica is not here she was
here yesterday but her work let's start
of it and in fact there are multiple
techniques that are doing private linear
regression that use the additive random
noise either on the output on your
objective function but it's the additive
random noise just as a comment both of
these techniques require that my loss
function is very good arised because I
need to control the sensitivity of this
linear regression regression query ok
now comes the fact that on a data set
that has many attributes people run will
want to run many regressions you would
want you know this may be why in this
particular X or this particular X or a
different choice of wine a different
choice altogether of X a dataset cannon
data set with the dimensions can yield
exponentially many regressions in d
so we can solve all of them if I just
publish the second moment matrix of the
data because this is the one quantity
all the variances and covariances
between the different features that will
allow to run any aggression you want on
any number of variables and because it's
such a common thing today there are also
known algorithms to how to release the
second moment matrix one of them of
working out like every other paper in
the fraction privacy working out just
uses the additive Gaussian noise on the
matrix itself on the second moment
matrix itself and releases it and they
analyzed it for the terms of PC ok so
this concludes the bivvy the overview
hopefully now i'll start talking about
things that were new to me please i'm
not a statistician
now the definition that is presented for
differential privacy seem suited for
discrete value things but here you are
going to output parameters which are
real number so is this is definitely
same definition it's the same definition
it's the when I released the author of
my mechanism earth with the additive
random noise it is a reactive real
number and it's the definition type i
glossed over yeah but it is it would be
the same definition it's for any subset
of the wheels okay linear regression as
everyone else been extensively stuck in
the days of Gauss and you know there are
I think 500 books about it in the
University of the old bread alone and
I'm sure here in Berkeley there are many
more I of course have not read them but
in all the literature about linear
regression none of the existing
techniques of linear regression uses
this additive Gaussian noise mechanism
none of them take the second moment
matrix the data and add to it random
Gaussian matrix they do variety of other
things they do a variety of
regularization you know people talk a
lot about the LA circularization that
helps people find sparsity but in this
talk I actually want to talk about the
ridge regression or l2 regularization
where to the classic problem of linear
regression i'm adding this l2 penalty
term and you know the standard reproach
of what should be the penalty term how
do i find that the actual coefficient
here try all 32 flavors you know try
them run your regression in multiple
variation in in multiple values of the
salon de take the one that minimizes the
risk it depends on the data and the
approach i'm going to talk about here is
you know completely data independent it
was going to be set this lambda to
preserve purpose
this richer question comes with numerous
justifications in literature or
different ways to look at it first of
all you can see it as the laplacian of
solving the regression with a bounded l2
norm hey laganja sorry the lagrangian
yeah sorry that's the problem with
speaking you lose IQ points when you're
talking front of audience anyway the the
lagrangian of abounded LT problem a
different way to see it is that I take
my original data that only had only that
had n observations and i pair it with
particular d minus 1 or d points that
are you know the identity over each
feature and 0 over this Y or I can even
do it completely with the identity over
the OL feature lambda times the identity
on all those features because the last
one will be all zeros on X so it won't
change the value of the optimization or
the e sorry it won't give me a different
minimizer and different way to say is to
say that this is a Beijing version of
the linear regression I start with a
prior on the beta's sampled from a
spherical Gaussian and I know how this
spherical Russian relates to the
standard error in each observation and
based of that i'm updating to the
posterior distribution and this beta are
the the one that solves the ridge
regression is the maximum a posteriori
of the problem
based on that you can start thinking on
words and say what else can we do with
linear regression and these types of
penalty terms there are two other
options that I've considered one is
using a random regularization rather
than adding this particular term to my
objective let's use a random term all
right random features random labels
let's use that let's put my data with
that or let's put my problem with this
particular random set of examples a
different version is maybe instead of
doing the maximum posteriori of the
Beijing posterior our sample from the
posterior distribution now I can do it
for the beta itself but it requires me
to know the variance of each observation
which can be computed but I'm not going
to talk about here here is an
alternative approach to this Beijing
sampling don't simple the bay the beta
sample the variance covariance matrix
from the posterior distribution so have
a prior on the variance covariance
update that prior based on each
observation that you see you get a new
posterior observation Christy
redistribution sample from it okay and
then in for Swisher it's the simplest
though I know if it's the simplest but
it's a rather simple conjugate prior
that people use for this prestigious
sampling or the posterior distribution
okay so now that I've introduced this
inverse we sure let me let me say what
are those wishard and everything what
are all these distributions gaussians
are great right we all love gaussians
and we love them so much you know but
what you know what's better than a
gumption to gaussians or multiple
gunshots right simple many iid gaussians
and now that i have multiple ID
gaussians i can look at the norm of what
I get all right if this is the vector
observation I can look at the norm of
this vector and it turns out that it's
tightly concentrated around k this is
the chi-square distribution because
everyone loves goshen so we came up with
new distribution the chi-square
distribution is the distribution on the
square norm of this vector and I can
also manipulate those linear manipulate
linearly the gumption to get a
multivariate Gaussian and that's the
definition basically of a multivariate
caption and then how that I have access
to a multivariate Gaussian like like
uncle in you know instead of just using
one dimension let's use multiple
dimensions are sample many examples from
this high dimension gunshot I
dimensional Gaussian and then I look at
the second moment matrix of my samples
and that's called the Wishart
distribution and it has a closed form
for its PDF in fact people like the way
her distribution so much that they
invented the inverse Wishart
distribution which basically says my
matrix comes from the inverse Fisher
distribution if its inverse comes from
the wizard distribution of the inverse
scaling scale matrix
okay now are with all of these
definitions I can basically give you the
spill this field can give you the
theorems the privacy theorem that using
additive weezer noise or sampling from
the wisher distribution or from the
inverse with your distribution all of
those preserve epsilon delta
differentially / differential privacy
given that the matrix that I'm using has
large enough scale so the what I'm
talking about basically is more more
about the sampling I need the sampling
from the wisher distribution that my
scale matrix has is well spread has
large I ghen values but basically what
we started with this triangle of privacy
versus accuracy versus the size of the
data now becomes a niceness property if
I want low privacy laws and good
accuracy I better use the sampling on
really nice matrices that are very very
well sprint and the trade of now goes
between this three parameters okay feel
free for the way to ask questions here
is the note the clifford version of the
theorem the privacy theorems basically
if i have a matrix and observation each
one of them has a bounded l2 norm then
each of the following algorithms is
privacy-preserving take the second
moment and use additive random noise
from the wisher distribution parameters
are has to be said or if the data is
nice all the singular values are greater
than a particular WN this is the form
for W then I can sample from the wizard
distribution or the inverse Wishart
distribution
so this always works and this only works
if the input is nice take eat a you take
theme the actual second diversity and
you answer it random noise a sample from
this distribution this is the additive
random north okay take the output of
your query and add to it randoms
you think reduced so what you do is say
here is a certain particular threshold
did I need you know all them all the
parameters are mixed together into this
threshold if my data is nice if it is
well spread then I can sample from the
wisher distribution centered around the
v cv or the from the inverse ratio
distribution center elevation and it
will preserve pipes is just outputting
that simple phrase in one you're doing
just you're taking a sample from
essentially identity matrix around the
identity matrix yes where is actually
with your sampling around the covariance
exactly
and because this definition of niceness
is so simple then when the data is nice
I can actually use it as is when it's
not nice i can make it nice and this
making it nice padding it into making it
with large enough singular values can be
done in a way that really correspond to
these analyses for the first one it's
like it will correspond to the ridge
regularization and the second one it
will correspond to a well spread prior
I'm assuming the well spread prior I
updated the posterior will also be well
spread so I'm sampling from it and it
will be nice so just to recap this
analogous things the additive random
noise that working out paper I don't
think there is an analogous existing
technique that corresponds to it nicely
the sampling from a wisher distribution
is like thinking like you projecting the
data with a Johnson induced our students
form and it will correspond to the ridge
regression sampling from the inverse
wisher distribution will correspond to
sampling from a pursuer distribution
according to Beijing analysis and the
additive wizard will correspond to
either using random regularization or
padding my data with random set of
points the beauty is that all of this
have been studied before like this is a
really tight really small list of cs
papers that talk about linear regression
that have been extensively studying
statistics so ridge reversion Beijing
where the use of random vocalizations
have all been studied before so we can
literally take those techniques and use
them as is or use their utility analysis
as is the thing that needed proof is
that why is there actually preserving
privacy
okay so i give you the privacy theorems
yeah I have enough time so i think what
i want to do is actually give you the
proof overview for a very simple one
dimensional case for the at least the
additive version is that if there are
any other questions but at least on the
one dimension let's consider the case
where a very simple input my data is a
vector of zeros and ones so d transpose
D is just summing up those VI squared
which will just summing up the DI
because there's zero and one so a deep
prime differs on one entry
I'm confused yeah it was a matrix and
I'm saying let's take a matrix of one
dimension the simplest thing right and
even discreet input when they get even
simpler and then d prime transpose D
prime is basically d transpose D plus 1
just the number of ones plus or minus
but plus i chose plus ok so basically ok
you raise the directions sorry ever so
basically I'm sampling from a I'm
petting what I will do this additive
wizard will be simple simple from I'm a
chi-square distribution of k's degrees
of freedom and then just publish I
either publish it's a number degrees of
freedom and that's the number of
examples
this is the particular form of key which
happens to be dependent on D plus
something dependent on one over epsilon
rather than x that was quite surprising
and took a little bit of effort but in
our case d is 1 so it's basically one
over epsilon squared so in either
releasing this D transpose D plus the
sample or releasing this D transpose D
plus 1 plus my sample so I'm comparing
the pdfs of the two distribution it's
basically getting a on the sky squared
getting a versus getting a minus one all
right because if the value I got was a
it was some sort of X then I got this X
minus this difference posed in here and
X minus one here ok chi-squared
distribution is proportional to sorry
its PDF
proportional to X to the K over 2 minus
1 times e to the minus X so what I will
get here is just a to the K over 2 minus
1 n minus 1 K over 2 minus 1 e oh
there's a half here
yeah sorry it's a ex mine over 2 and e
to the half
just a little bit of manipulation this
would be one minus
times e to the half
and this is at most e to the K minus 2
over a minus one half plus half hope
this is not too low for you guys to see
so remember a is what I sampled from the
case where from the chi-square
distribution
it is known that because gaussians are
tightly concentrated around the mean
then the chi-squared distribution is
tightly concentrated around me so it is
known that with probability greater
equal one minus Delta a is in the range
of square root of k plus minus pretty
sure that this is the full version
it'll be roughly k plus 4 square root of
K which means
some- here that i forgot
it should be e to the minus half
so what I end up getting from there the
exponent not this minus half plus half
of K minus 2k minus I don't know eight
square root of K lon one over Delta and
glossing over constants and this term is
very close to one because of these are
in opposite signs this half minus half
plus half of one and then this is
roughly like plus 8 square root of K
over K
so everything here is upper bounded by e
to the minus one over square root of K
and neglecting console
I'm not sure that you've been able to
follow but what's really going on here
is something that is in common to all
these proofs about wishard in the
standard case our ratio of PDFs has
these two terms one comes from the
determinant which was it's
one-dimensional event was this the
polynomial term one comes from the
exponent some linear manipulation
carries this to the exponent and then in
my exponent I get a sample from a
chi-squared distribution minus its mean
so the proof of privacy actually goes
through the chi-square concentration
distribution or the Johnson lindenstraße
saying that this is not far off from
what it's expected to be and for those
of you who do know something about
differential privacy this is how you cut
through bypass the off-the-shelf
composition that will require some lock
factors this emits the log vectors by
looking at the exact distribution yeah
so basically some quantity X and some
sample from a chi square distribution
centered around centered around the same
thing and I get a difference which is
about square root of this well you okay
if you were able to follow great if not
that's also fine that's basically what i
wanted to tell
is it sort of natural to think of this
as sort of saying in regularization if
you're wanting to generalize you
probably don't want what any single data
point throw your apnea regression off
and so regularization twice to avoid
that that's almost exactly the same sort
of thing that you want for privacy which
is you don't want any date of any single
data point to be revealed and the result
exactly what analog really motivate a
lot of the notion of stability that
captures both of them precisely it's the
great implies realization and stability
in some sense is equivalent privacy and
it's precisely that and as much as I
would love to take credit for it as I
said come alica and clear and and they
they started with the regularization but
you need this regularization what sort
of is my contribution is the fact that
you really need nice instance you do the
sampling you need you can't have them
really tightly concentrated and that's
sort of like the word duplicity the pic
if you use extra cash equation to solve
these things that also in fact give you
stronger than this because you every
time she beautiful to taking around
insulting this instead but there are
ways to solve it for stochastic doing
stuck at pro using stochastic gradient
descent to preserve privacy that's
completely true the only thing is that
that will be for particular regression
problem that's not for the releasing the
vcd matrix I do not know how to do
gradient descent with we listening to
this if he makes
more questions okay so more question
then let's thank over again